Dear
fellow citizens, 2016 was a year of difficult tests.
I would like to talk to you about this tonight,
but also about why I
am confident about Germany despite everything and
why I am so convinced of the strengths of
our country and its people.
Without a doubt, the most difficult test is
Islamist terrorism, which has also had its sights on
us Germans for many years
, attacked us in the middle of
our country in Würzburg in Ansbach in 2016
and only a few days ago at the
Christmas market here at the
Memorial Church in Berlin
and yes, it is particularly bitter and
disgusting when terrorist attacks are carried out by
people  committed are those who are
allegedly seeking protection in
our
country, who have experienced the helpfulness of our country for precisely this reason and are now
mocking them with their actions, just as they are
mocking those who actually
need and deserve our protection,
so what about the
confidence I spoke of at the beginning  confidence
in  in the midst of the deep mourning for the dead
and injured
i think we could feel it here in berlin
and in many other german cities
especially in these difficult days
in the consolation that we can donate or
receive and in the firm
determination of the world of hatred of
terrorists ours
to oppose humanity and our cohesion
by going about our lives and our
work we say to the
terrorists
they are murderers full of hate but they don't determine how we
live and want to live
aleppo in
syria being able to say once again how
important and right it was that our
country helped
those who actually
need our protection
to take hold of us and to integrate in the past year
all of this is reflected in our
democracy in our constitutional state  in
our values
you are the g  alternative draft to the
hateful world of terrorism and
you will be stronger than
terrorism we are stronger together
our state is stronger our state is doing
everything to ensure its citizens safety in
freedom
this work is never finished and
just this year we have given the
security authorities many new ones
support given in
2017,
where political or legal
changes are necessary, we as the federal
government will initiate and implement the necessary measures as quickly as possible.
many associate this year
2016 with the feeling that the world as a whole
has gotten out of joint or that which
was considered an achievement for a long time  now be
in question the european union,
for example, or the
parliamentary democracy that
supposedly doesn't care about the interests of the
citizens but only about the
benefits of a few what caricatures
europe is slow
it's tedious it has deep cuts
like the exit ei  accepting a member
state and yes
europe should concentrate on
what it can really do better than the
national start
but no we
germans should never let
ourselves be fooled a happy future could ever
lie in going it alone nationally where europe
as well as in global competition in protecting
our external borders or with
migration as a whole is challenged as a whole
it must also find the answer as a whole
no matter how tedious and tough it is
and we
germans have every interest in playing a leading role in this
it is also a distorted picture that some paint of
our parliamentary democracy
but it is strong  it enables
participation and participation it accepts
no it demands contradiction and criticism
criticism that comes peacefully and with respect for
the individual that
seeks solutions and compromises and does not
exclude entire groups 2017 is also
the year of the next federal elections
i will support a politisc
we will
argue passionately about many things
but always like democrats who never
forget that it is an honor for our
democracy and thus to
serve the people what gives me courage for our
germany also includes our social
market economy
it allows us crises and
master change processes better than
any other economic system in the
world never before have so many people had
work as today our companies
are mostly in good
shape because our economic success gives us
the opportunity to strengthen our social
system and to help all those who need help
starting tomorrow, for example, important
Improvements in care in
power I am also encouraged by the enthusiasm and
inventive spirit with which German
companies and our universities
conduct research and development for the future
whether new energies or
digitization we have the opportunity in all areas to
not driven
to be but to belong to those who
discover and determine new paths
for this it takes an open view of
the world and self-confidence in us and
our country cohesion openness our
democracy and a strong economy
that serves the well-being of all that's what
I think for our  the future here in
germany, even at the end of a difficult
year
, does not allow us to be optimistic none of these values ​​are
simply given
to us for everyone we will also have to work
together in 2017 everyone according to their
possibilities
and this work will be worthwhile i
wish you and your
families a heartfelt  happy new year
happiness health and god bless